foreign
celebrated my 10-year wedding
anniversary congratulations again yes
that was amazing and we had a ton of fun
Daria met me out there we did a
moonbirds Meetup so we had over a
hundred Japanese speaking Moon Birds
collectors out there which was
challenging and awesome at the same time
and then Henry my zen instructor here
shookman here in the United States
introduced me to the head of his lineage
of Zen
who I got to go out and meet with and
sit down with and have a good carry out
David yeah exactly we're not drinking
and just karaoke together all night long
no but we we had a little private
Gathering and sit down and did a a
private delays on you exercise the
demons there was there was he helped me
with my practice and game he speaks his
English is quite good and
it was it was very intimidating very bad
three Treasures like a big lineage of
Zen and I'm sitting here with this guy
you know and he's just like asking me
very pointed questions about my
intention what is your intention with my
daughter yeah more or less but it was
like very cutting questions dude like
like what Like a Surgeon just coming in
and just like
I don't know if I should say the things
because it's this private interview you
know he gave me all the [__] with not
being able to come up with the brand of
privacy protector okay all right no it's
just
it's just like it asks me all these
amazing questions now I can't talk I'll
give you an example it's like he's like
it's more or less like
why are you here like where are you
you know how in Zen they have these
these phrase we've talked about these
cons before you've done interviews with
Henry and thank you for doing those like
yeah where it's like these moments where
of really good zen master can come in
and look at a student and know kind of
exactly the little nudge they need to
give them there's these like moments
where they they call it like there's
these stories in Zen World they grab
your coat and yank you in a certain
direction just to kind of get you to
like Snap like wake up like you know
this moment just boom they want you to
pop yeah and it was very much that like
why are you here what do you what do you
want from this like boom boom boom like
this rapid fire like I think the guy
looks real and I walked back to my
Airbnb in Venice asked me those
questions
exactly and
less fentanyl driven but yeah so it was
amazing it was very special here this is
a masters have cut back on their fennel
a lot yeah this guy was operating in a
gym so what does that feel like for you
like what was why did you want to do it
first of all because I just you know
Henry had said such great things about
him that
you know and Henry is is he will never
say this publicly but I believe he is
one I'll say it for him no I will
because I think it's important like he
he's he's such a modest guy that like
Henry is one of I think it's like five
or so it's like fully sanctions and
Masters in this lineage and that's a big
deal when there's you know hundreds of
teachers in this in this realm so
you know this is his master his teacher
if you get a chance to take that meeting
you take it you know and so you know I
wouldn't you know like no I'm busy yeah
I'm gonna try on some new shoes I'm too
too busy going going to try some fancy
Japanese coffee but
which I did which is amazing Cafe mamea
out there is fantastic but honestly
though the one thing that I I took away
from it for for people that that I will
share is that one of the things that he
asked me is he's like how how often do
you practice and how long do you
practice and I said you know I practice
25 minutes a day probably five days a
week and he goes what about the other
two days and I go well I got to start up
I got this I got that and he goes I
don't care and I'm paraphrasing here
because I don't care if you've practiced
five minutes a day he goes don't miss a
day don't break a day continue to do it
don't don't miss a day and
since then I have not missed a day and I
will say it's it's kind of amazing
because even if you can sit down for
five minutes it just keeps that
continuity going and it actually keeps
me at a slightly elevated more
I don't know it keeps the commitment
stronger like it feels better and that
was that was Sound Advice
Square device sorry can I trouble if
you're just a little bit of water please
thank you so much
what's water
you can do it hold on
hold on don't tell me yeah you got it
uh Oishi
what Oishi no that's tasty yeah I know
the water's tasty
out there so let's stay on the Japanese
yeah
this is a book in front of me which I'm
just digging into
Japanese death poems let's talk about
Japanese death poems I did not actually
embarrass to admit no this was the thing
this was given to me by a friend
who has spent a lot of time in military
and has
developed a rather unique perspective
unique perspectives on death
from I suppose the vantage point of a
layperson right of a civilian and so
this book
is I'll I'll just read the quote on the
back this is one of the
the blurbs a wonderful introduction to
the Japanese tradition of GC this volume
is crammed with exquisite spontaneous
verse epitheof and hilarious
descriptions of The Eccentric and
committed monastics who wrote the poems
so these poems are written on the verge
of death and literally the subtitle is
written by Zen monks and Haiku poets on
the verge of death yes and it's
incredibly well researched you have not
just the English versions of the
introduction and all the context you
have the Japanese and then you have
footnotes describing what these various
words might mean what the metaphors
allude to and
it's really
just a phenomenal window into an aspect
of Japanese culture that I had no
exposure to
I would have expected that I would have
been exposed to this before but
I am I'm looking forward to diving into
this and I've already read perhaps the
first 10 pages so this is Japanese death
poems so fun by Tuttle publishing
compiled in with an introduction by
Joelle Hoffman
so I have a handful I don't know if I
told you this but I have a handful of
haiku books that I've read by Japanese
Masters yeah and one of the things I
always felt was just so beautiful about
them is they always include their kind
of death poems like at the very end it's
oftentimes like on their deathbed when
they're about to pass like what is the
last thing that they wrote down right
it's often in Haiku form if they're a
haiku Master right yeah and so it's just
it's beautiful stuff yeah there's some
really Japanese stuff in here right like
this has died 1698 for not honoring my
parents while I lived in my last hour I
feel remorse that is very super Japanese
the Autumn Hues of not weeds seem like
cups of wine
yeah
are you a big fan of haiku
I am this is my first time really being
exposed to a lot of Japanese
and it does sound better in Japanese
there's a certain Cadence to it
I'm not going to get the pronunciation
quite perfectly here but it's like if
you have okay so hakuro is this person
died on the 19th day of the 12th month
1766. so the English and I'm gonna [__]
this up in Japanese so I apologize to
any Japanese speakers out there but
the English just listen to the sounds
like the Cadence so the English is an
ailing Mallard falls through the chilly
night and Teeters off
okay but then the the Japanese is
right so it just like has has a cleaner
crisper Cadence to it which doesn't mean
you shouldn't do the English but this is
my first time being exposed to a lot of
haiku in Japanese which is fun for me
number one makes it very hard for me to
decipher in many cases but
they have a beautiful sound to them
so
that's awesome I have to pick that book
up death pumps yeah there's a great poem
about Haiku and about the Masters called
three simple lines okay have you ever
read that no it's a fantastic book that
is written by a Zen practitioner that
covers a lot of the the Zen masters of
haiku and along with a really beautiful
personal story so definitely worth a
very short read definitely worth picking
up along with this yeah I mean how
Japanese relate to death which is
something I have some exposure to but
not to the poems this particular you say
format
tells you a lot about how they live I
mean it does
provide sort of a prism through which
you can
appreciate how they navigate a lot of
life as well right like in addressing
the final hours and thinking about dying
death the path to death
when you get a better understanding of
that many of the things you observe in
Japanese culture make more sense
in a way